the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention tells CBS this morning that
the risk of new e coli infections from
tainted romaine lettuce is low but the
number of cases will rise that's because
the CDC says older infections will
likely be linked to the same strain of
bacteria originating in Arizona so far
149 people in 29 states have become sick
one person has died Mireya Villarreal is
at a farm in Yuma the Arizona region at
the center of the outbreak maria good
morning good morning the FDA has
identified one farm here in human that
supplied the lettuce that made eight
prisoners sick in Alaska that's eight
out of a hundred and forty nine cases so
far people here say that finding the
source of an outbreak is like trying to
find one haystack in thousands of acres
of land and going through that one
haystack to try and find the needle from
November to March John bolts fields are
filled with romaine and head lettuce
crops that have to pass some of the most
stringent safety guidelines as they go
from farm to for industry took it upon
ourselves to impose rules voluntary
rules that growers and shippers adhered
to so you go above and beyond what the
FDA already requires of the industry
absolutely in 2006 an e.coli outbreak
traced back to spinach from California
claimed three lives and made nearly 200
people sick bolt says the industry lost
millions of dollars by the time the Food
and Drug Administration traced this
outbreak back to romaine lettuce in the
Yuma Valley region growing season was
over the romaine fields are gone there
are new crops in its place and that's
what's frustrating to farmers that
investigators didn't get out here sooner
folks in our business will work as
closely with them as they would like and
try to get to the bottom of it but some
of these things can be very difficult to
identify especially weeks and months
after the fact in an email to CBS this
morning the FDA says available packaging
provides very limited information on the
source of the products and they welcome
anyone who has information that is
helpful to the ongoing investigation to
share it with them the FDA is already
getting help
from the CDC which used new genome
sequencing technology to link infections
to the same potent strain of e.coli the
CDC is deputy chief for outbreak
response
Matthew wise we do it this DNA
fingerprinting the intention of that is
is to try and connect different groups
of illnesses in different states
together to say actually this is
something bigger that's going on it's
not just a localized event we come out
will collect samples on the ground local
health officials and farmers work
closely with water safety specialists
Channel Rock she says the romaine could
have come in contact with e.coli through
humans at processing plants contaminated
water fertilizer or Wildlife we place a
lot of effort in identifying what types
of animals could come into the field
safety is focusing on what are all the
potential exposure routes and how do we
minimize those California farmers tell
us they have already seen a decline in
market and right now even though there
is no fresh romaine coming out of Yuma
the CDC is still recommending that you
not eat romaine lettuce
if you can't verify that it did not come
from the Yuma Valley region Noora
important update Maria thank you